depuis la nuit des temps
nous nous demandons ce qui est à
l'origine de l'univers
un schéma merveilleusement d'orchestrés
ou quelque chose de beaucoup beaucoup
plus bêtes
ton amour me donne des belles cuvées la
trouvaille de mes yeux veux tu être ma
femme aille pour la vie c'est fini entre
nous quoi en plus tu ressemble pas du
tout à sa photo de profil
cette année je veux pas grand chose
juste le grand amour
c'est vraiment trop de manques regardez
2 et paul schuler tout et je viens vous
je veux la firme de mes rêves ça sent
mauvais oui toi dit century fox présente
aux saluts mammifères buck
qu'est ce que tu fais là ce n'est qu'un
début le plus gros des astéroïdes se
dirige tout droit vers nous faut qu'on
aille là où les autres sont tombés qu'on
cherche des indices et qu'on trouve un
moyen d'arrêter
q et avec quoi cracher dit toujours prêt
à encaisser trois compères nos besoins
ok me sers mettront trop classe je serai
pas un problème ça franchement tu les
auditoires
manny ellie sid diego buck estrade vous
permettez question d'ambiance de l'âge
de glace
lilou à tout l'univers
j'ai l'impression chaque can oui je
confirme c'est complètement à part
celui-là